dear friends it's really a pleasure for
me to see so many of us gathering today
with a strong commitment to a peaceful
and stronger Somalia I would first of
all convey our appreciation and our
thanks for all of you and your
delegations for your presence and for
being here and first of all to the
president slowly but steadily Somalia is
emerging from decades of war and
instability and since we met in London
one year ago we've seen incredible
progress unfolding in Somalia since our
meeting in London last year the
government under you mr. president
and under Prime Minister has put
together an ambitious reform agenda for
inclusive politics economic recovery and
a security transition plan Somalia
starting to take responsibility for its
own security as we see in Mogadishu you
have agreed on an electoral model for
the elections in 2020 as well as how to
choices between the federal government
and the federal Member States we all
know that the road has been and will be
bumpy terrorist attacks against eight
buildings are regular reminders of this
and at the same time the people of
Somalia are confident that war and
instability who want to be for ever
there is a new hope and Somalia the
economy is likely picking up new
investments are flowing in the country
hundreds of Somali rates are putting
faith in their country returning to
their hometowns and opening your
businesses it is our duty as an
international community to support the
people of Somalia's hope and the
government's reform agenda we all know
that access to financial resources is
essential to any reconstruction process
the Somali government is now raising
more money than ever
through domestic revenues this is an
important achievement that we must
accompany and encourage today's forum
should also support Somalia on the path
to that relief and access to lending
from the international financial
institutions on the European side I am
glad to announce today an additional
part
of around 200 million euros in support
of Somalia stabilization this includes a
new 100 million contract for State
Building and state resilience we want in
particular to help the federal
government deliver on its citizens needs
and we want to help improve trust
between the federal government and
federal Member States Somalia can and
should be strong federal country where
central and local authorities were
together each one with its own
competences and specificities towards
the common goal of serving the people of
Somalia there is no better way to foster
a sense of belonging and of citizenship
within a common test of the package will
help to build state structures and
particularly security forces mainly is
that I've recently gone back to the
control of the Somali authorities this
is also a contribution to the
government's transition plan to help the
Somali authorities take full
responsibility for their own country and
for the citizens security because we all
know that economic recovery must go hand
in hand with an improved security
situation now today's forum the European
Union co-hosted with Somalia a security
conference here in Brussels for
engagement for peace and security in
Somalia continues to be as strong as
ever
as you know the European Union is active
in Somalia with three military and
civilian missions training the police
and the Armed Forces and fighting piracy
of the Horn of Africa coastal we have
recently extended our missions until the
end of 2020 we have also adopted their
mandates to an evolving situation on the
ground and to new needs from our Somali
partners the European Union has also
been a leading international supporter
of AMISOM the African Union's mission to
Somalia since it's very inception into
2007 and I would like to thank my friend
the Commissioner of the African Union
Commission because we have worked very
well together in this as well as in many
other fields thanks to Amazon your
African brothers and sisters have given
a great contribution to peace in Somalia
and they continue to pay a high
price in terms of human lives peace in
Somalia is an interest we all share and
the peacekeeping mission is still
essential for the time being so the
European Union will continue to support
M ISM and in a few minutes
I will sign together with the African
Union's Commissioner for peace and
security
my friends smile surely a new 114
million euro package to finance Amazon's
activities in the second half of this
year however for security and
stabilization to be sustainable Somali
authorities have to be in the driving
seat when dealing with security in their
country and this will not happen
overnight we all know it but progress
has happened and continues to have them
the government and the federal Member
States have agreed on a transition plan
just been fully endorsed by the
international community the plan is to
be operationalized in three pilot
locations the transition will be faced
and based on clear conditions this
transition entails a gradual assumption
of security controlled by Somali forces
in the meantime armed ISM will continue
to evolve in parallel as conditions are
met for the final goal to withdraw and
hand over to integrated trained and
effective Somali forces this process
will only be successful if we all keep a
unity of purpose following the path
chosen by the Somali authorities and
here the African Union Amazon and the
troop contributing countries have a
crucial role to play it is essential
that we operate through the coordination
structures we have agreed to in a
transparent and complimentary fashion
this is a very special moment for the
Horn of Africa I'm also glad to have a
friends from the region here and for the
broader region
if the opie and Eritrea has to have
taken historic decision towards peace
and reconciliation this is a message to
all of us every obstacle can be overcome
with political will and with courage as
the UN secretary-general said I quote a
new wind of hope is blowing across
Africa we have a collective duty to
support such hope both inside Somalia
and in the region international tensions
only help al-shabaab we all have an
interest in
peaceful and secure Somalia and we all
have an interest in a peaceful and
secure Horn of Africa this is our common
region at the crossroads between Central
Africa Africa and the gulf between the
Mediterranean Sea and the Indian Ocean
the window of hope in the country and in
the region is an opportunity we must and
we can not waste for the people of
Somalia but also for a common and
troubled would I thank you very much it
is now my honor and pleasure to give the
floor to the President of the Federal
Republic of Somalia His Excellency
Mohamed Abdullahi Muhammad good
afternoon
excellencies distinguished guests and
ladies and gentlemen it's an honor to
address this partnership forum for
Somalia looking around the room I see
many friends colleagues with whom we
enjoy an effective and meaningful
partnership in Somalia I recognize the
high-level delegation from all partners
in this room which include ministers
ambassadors and other senior government
officials given the importance of this
partnership for some modest progress I
thank you all most sincerely for your
participation the Somali government
extends its sincere gratitude to the
European Union and some member states
Sweden for co-hosting this partnership
forum in Brussels the home of the EU
itself we are cognizant that Somalia
would not have made such clear and
tangible progress without the
partnership of other vital delegations
represented here today in particular the
African Union United Nations USA Turkey
and all of the EU member states the
centrality and the unity and unity of
goal to achieve sustainable development
in all it is forms in Somalia it is an
honor that we are able
to convene our progressive discussions
on Somalis future here in process
following our last successful meeting
meeting in Mogadishu six months ago this
is not the first time important Somali
partnership meeting were held in
Brussels a city which embodied embodies
a vital message of unity and common
purpose and exemplifies progress after
painful destruction like nowhere else in
the world it is the place where
Europeans Europe's pledge of never again
returning to war is preserved and upheld
we are determined to learn this lesson
and move forward to build a strong
secure progressive and prosperous nation
for the benefit of our resilient people
in this globalized world there has there
has to be a reliable need for an
effective partnership we are all benefit
from enabling opportunities and
overcoming common challenges like
insecurity poverty such challenges are
the underlying causes of illegal
immigrations
in the past the scale of Somalis
challenges has made its relationship
with parlors somewhat unbalanced we were
not able to play our role to the fullest
extent in setting the priorities in
leading the implementation of
initiatives or in directing the
resources while we are sincerely
grateful to all our partners we want
Somalia to be the tip of the Spirit in
all reform processes and their
implementation we must be trusted to
lead our transformation with renewed
capacity and commitment in all our
valuable discussions in this partnership
forum I hope you realized that the
Somali government is committed to take
greater responsibility to generate and
disperse domestic revenue to achieve
debt relief to strengthen security to
progressively shift from you immaterial
aid to development support and to
prepare the path for Somalis to engage
in a domestic process in 2020 all these
national efforts are vital to our
partnership and we will lead towards the
realization of our set goals allowing
Somalia to play its rightful role as a
primary player for state building our
discussions that largely revolve around
interconnected issues prove is the
importance of effective and diverse
partnerships and strategic coordination
both internal and external I acknowledge
that there are no quick fix to resolve
all Somalis challenges but strong
commitment hard work and consistent
evaluation are needed to achieve
tangible result on that note there
should be no single issue that would be
allowed to undermine a cohesive process
towards stability accountability and
development the internal into the
interconnected nature of inclusive
politics security economic reform and
building human and environmental
resilience should be emphasized the
urgency of working with a mutual
accountability framework we will
accelerate progress by capitalizing on
our individual strengths and collective
resources for maximum impact for the
benefit of the Somali people
I am confident of our collective
commitment and I am sure together we
will fulfill our promise of moving
forward together soon as the Somali
partnership forum in Mogadishu in
December 2017 Somalia has taken
significant steps to move forward in
inclusive politics economic recovery and
reform security and the foster and the
fostering of resilience among our people
I have personally taken the lead
supported by my able prime minister has
an elevator and his cabinet and his
company to ensure that what was agreed
in all this area was addressed
in many cases and implemented since then
we have successfully completed the
second International Monetary Fund's
staff monitoring program and we are now
progressing a third to a third one with
an even more stringent set of benchmarks
we have implemented a five percent sales
tax on imports and this has so far
raised domestic revenue by around and
one million per month we acknowledge
that inclusive politics is a must if we
are to fully overcome the past quagmire
of poor governance injustice and
conflict accordingly as part of the
political reform agenda we have
initiated the vital constitutional
review process to address the anomalies
in the provisional Constitution the
National Constitution convention held in
Mogadishu on the 30th on the on the 13
of May this year brought together all
relevant Somali stakeholders to discuss
and guide the future direction of our
country inclusive politics is always a
challenge particularly so in a
recovering post-conflict state we are
determined to get it right and
sustainably move forward as a people and
country no Somali shall be left behind
or forgetting in this process the
historic pay double agreement has
stablished a common position and
framework for internal partnership on
inclusive politics economic reform
security and resilience this is a
significant steps in the right direction
especially since the process was and
will remain Somalia led and Somalia
owned for this I am grateful to all the
leaders of the third member states of
Somalia as well as our international
partners in addition this government is
engaged all stakeholders beginning with
the Somali people and the business
community to play their part in our in
our national transformation since our
last polish
form in December last year in Mogadishu
our government has increased its
engagement and partnership with a
private sector we are tackling
corruption and human rights violation
through legislation and education and we
are nurturing the stable consensus based
politics that will allow us to achieve
inclusive politics I am proud to
announce that after many years of trials
we have finally begun biometrically
registering the Somali soldiers in
addition to that we have completed a
viable transition plan there is a
concrete evidence of our government's
commitment to security reform economic
progress and strengthening partnership
in the next six to 12 months the federal
government will continue to concentrate
it is effort on advancing the key
priorities of state building on
inclusive politics economic reform
security and building resilience while
the while the role of our value valuable
partners will continue to be critical
this role support must focus more on
strengthening Somali institutions
capacity to lead and deliver for Somalis
for Somali people the much war
accountability framework is the basis of
Somalis partnership with the
international community the Somali
government is working tirelessly to
improve the systems and processes that
will further increase our ability to
deliver vital basic services to our
people in this respect notably progress
has been made and I wish to acknowledge
all our major partners including the
international financial institutions and
the EU who are pledging more resources
your support for Somali economic
development allows us to work towards
debt relief and the expansion of
opportunity opportunities for the Somali
people in all our bilateral and
multilateral discussions we agreed that
Somali progress will be holistic
and inclusive with accountability
leadership from the federal government
we are all committed to this the recent
National Security Council meeting
embeddable and its outcome proves our
strong willingness to collaborate and
cooperate Somalia and its federal Member
States see a future of common prosperity
where we cooperate meaningfully on the
path to inclusive development and
engagement accordingly we urge all our
international partners to incorporate
this into their support and assistance
Somalia is one entity united by a shared
vision and driven by a common purpose in
the in favour of all the Somali people I
am proud to say we are truly together
excellencies distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen much progress has been
made in improving our country systems
this would not have been possible
without the support of many of our
valuable partners
therefore in line with our fiscal
banking and economic reforms we urge all
partners to commit to using our
country's system to channel their
development support and assistance
Somali its resources and opportunities
are boundless Somalia offers investors
and partner government's a golden
opportunity to bridge profit and social
progress investment will also lead to
long term job creation penetration of
new markets and a real deduction in aid
support budgets investment can turn in
aid into a trade and reject we inject
hope and spirit of entrepreneurial and
turbine or ship in Somali youth
excellency distinguished it justice
ladies and gentlemen we have before us a
stork opportunity for enhancing
partnership built on our mutual
accountability framework to deliver
accelerated progress for our benefit we
need to work
even more closely to achieve our
objectives of stability and progress in
Somalia my government intends to move
this country forward with our partners
steadfast support partnership is crucial
for Somalia it gives us means in
recognizing strengthening and promoting
Somalis desire to assume responsibility
across the spectrum of development and
progress issues issues I once again urge
all our valuable partners to do this by
aligning all support with the priorities
set by the Somali government in the
national development plan finally I wish
to pay tribute to the African Union and
the men and women of AMISOM whose
bravery and sacrifice has been essential
to saw Molly's progress we are grateful
for your critical role in supporting my
government and the people of Somalia I
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president it's not my
pleasure to give the floor to the
foreign minister of Sweden my good
friend margot wallström that is
co-chairing with me this for Thank You
mr. president excellencies ladies and
gentlemen we have gathered here today
and I'm really proud to be on the podium
together with these good people around
me to reinforce our joint commitments
take stock of progress made so far and
agree on the next steps in our
partnership with Somalia
there is real momentum as we've heard
created by the hard work of Somali
stakeholders and facilitated by strong
support from the international community
we need to continue forward together or
is it the Yala forward together building
on progress and aligning our efforts to
promote peaceful and prosperous
development in Somalia I hope that
today's meeting will take us forward
together along four major themes first
state building and women's participation
and as the new federal map of Somalia
has taken shape Somalia has reached a
point in its state and peace building
process where reforms will be
increasingly difficult requiring
numerous compromises and concessions and
it is my conviction that the only way to
achieve sustainable peace is through
truly inclusive political processes in
fact building democracy means building a
system of peaceful conflict resolution
state building will only be successful
when women hold political positions at
all levels and participate actively in
society it is crucial for Somalia's
continued development that women play an
influential role on par with that of the
men to ensure that the federal member
states can contribute to Somalia speech
building process the federal government
needs to take steps to strengthen the
state
it's capacity and the recent violent
clashes in north northern Somalia
highlight the urgent need to find
peaceful and lasting solutions to
Somalia's political challenges second
the need for security for security
related reforms which has generated
several agreements over the last year
the transition plan is instrumental in
this regard it demonstrates Somalia's
commitment to working towards systemic
responsibility for the country's
security and it is in the interest of
all of us to ensure the successful
implementation of the transition plan a
hasty and premature drawdown of AMISOM
forces risks undermining the hard-won
gains against al-shabaab we therefore
need to strike a balance between wanting
to see quick progress and being mindful
of the patience required to reach a
long-term goal a secure and stable
Somalia at peace with itself and its
neighbors I am particularly pleased and
grateful to see distinguished
representatives of the TCC's here today
without your important efforts the
achievements of the past few years would
not have been possible your continued
contribution to our mission remains
equally instrumental in securing
Somalia's long-term stability my third
point is that Somalia is on the
threshold of a new financial foundation
continued commitment to the
implementation of financial programs
with the IMF and World Bank has open
prospects for concessional financing and
a pathway to depth relief to continue on
this positive track international
support should be geared towards the
implementation of these crucial reforms
and fourth and finally I would like to
stress this need for all of us to align
our efforts I urge all of Somalia's
neighbors on both sides of the Red Sea
to work together to ensure regional
cooperation for the good of Somalia and
the wider Horn of Africa the recent
positive developments in the region in
particular the rapprochement between
Ethiopia Eritrea renew our belief
in a peaceful and prosperous Horn of
Africa as for Sweden our commitment to
Somalia is long-term and solid Swedish
Somali ties go back decades and they run
deep the Somali diaspora in Sweden
represents no less than 1% of our
population of today participates in all
parts of society and includes by now
parliamentarians musicians and non
tripping oars the diaspora is not only a
vibrant part of our society but also of
our bilateral relations just the other
week the Swedish government as I've
already said today decided to double our
development aid to Somalia to
approximately 350 million US dollars
over the next five years the primary
target areas of the new strategy include
some of those we are addressing here
namely sustainable peace resilience and
gender equality and one concrete example
of our capacity-building efforts is
Sweden five national agencies working in
Somalia this doubling of our financial
support together with our current work
is testimony to Swedish long-term
commitment to enhancing our partnership
based on mutual respect and a belief in
Somalia's potential I want to close by
thanking you all for coming to this
important event your participation is a
clear expression of your support to
Somalia development and I encourage all
of us to remain engaged in keeping the
positive developments on track forward
together thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Margo also for all the work
written together
and preparing this important meeting
today and let me now pass the floor to
the African Union peace and security
Commissioner my good friends miles
Sharkey thank you very much my dear
friend federica mogherini high
representative and vice-president of the
European Commission
His Excellency Mohammed Abdullah
Mohammed president of the Federal
Republic of Somalia Her Excellency mrs.
margot wallström
minister of foreign affairs of the
kingdom of Sweden Her Excellency
rosemary De Carlo un
under-secretary-general for political
affairs distinguished ministers ladies
and gentlemen we meet here today at this
partnership forum in a period when
Somalia is on the cusp of taking
ownership of its own future this is a
clear indication that our collective
investment in Somalia are yielding
results as we look to engage over the
next day and health the Africa Union
looks forward to deliberation that will
contribute to a brighter and more
prosperous future for all Somalis I
would like to seek this opportunity to
highlight some of the significant
progress we at the African Union and
Amazon have made since the last forum in
early December 2017 first let me remind
us that at the last partnership forum
both the African Union and AMISOM
committed themselves to a set of key
milestones this includes the reduction
of the number of Amazon troops by 1,000
in favour of police as required under
Security Council resolution 23 72 and to
gradually transfer security
responsibilities to Somali security
forces the above commitments in addition
to the three priorities agreed at the
Mogadishu Security Conference set the
basis for an action plan a key component
of this was the necessity of developing
a transitional plant jointly by the
federal
government of Somalia federal Member
States AMISOM and with the support of
the international partners likewise link
to develop in a transitional plan has
been the need to explore funding
arrangement not only for Amazon but also
for the Somali security forces
excellencies I want to highlight the
significant progress that Africa and
AMISOM have made leading up to this
forum this include Amazon drawing down
by 1,000 in December 2017 in favour of
police personnel be the development of
transitional plan in partnership with
the federal government and federal
Member States see the endorsement of the
transitional plan by the African Peace
and Security Council on the 30th April
2018
decoe authorizing the Africa Union UN
invoice report on Amazon financing a the
endorsement of the Africa Union UN joint
review on Amazon reportedly to the
African Peace and Security Council
meeting in ruptured Mauritania on 27 of
June 2018 this and other development
highlight the commitment of the African
Union and Amazon towards contributing to
the federal government's enter connected
reform agenda on security inclusive
politics and the economics excellencies
with the Africa Union Amazon continued
support Somalia has made considerable
progress to securing peace and stability
however Somalia still faces many
challenges such as pace of national
reconciliation and the finalization of
the constitutional review fundamental
processes towards building consensus
among so many stakeholders on the nature
of the federal Somalia similarly the
Africa Union wishes to see considerable
progress towards the competition of the
implementation of the national security
architecture as called for during the
recent concluded National Security
Council summit in Baidoa
to continue tensions between center and
periphery particularly around the
resources sharing and over the right
to engage in foreign affairs require
quick resolutions the risk of reversing
the gains made by Somalis partners
collective efforts in this regard
increase with delays in reaching an
agreement permit me at this point to
applaud the efforts of President Mohamed
Abdullah from a zoo in his attempts to
lead the rebuilding of viable security
sector in in Somalia the president's
efforts are rightly being a court on the
national security architecture agreement
between the federal government and the
federal Member States and currently the
transition plan as this forum is aware
the transition plan is geared to Somalis
long-term stability setting out priority
tasks and conditions that will support
the transfer of security
responsibilities from Amazon to the
Somali security sector over a four-year
period the African Union is proud of the
tangible progress made by both the
federal government and Amazon however
considerable effort and sacrifices are
still required to achieve a realistic
and viable transition currently the
implementation of the transitional plan
is in its initial stage AMISOM and
federal government are playing vital
roles in developing detailed operational
plan that focus on three pilot
priorities identified by the federal
government and based on the framework of
the comprehensive approach to security
in this context I am pleased to report
that the transition of Mogadishu stadium
is on schedule for a successful handover
this November in attempting to achieve
this self-imposed deadline AMISOM
uniformed personnel gallantly agreed to
transit to Jazeera to where the living
conditions are far below the standards
expected for our international
peacekeeper AMISOM will remain in Jazira
- until answers completes the Abbott
ation upgrade elsewhere AMISOM is closed
in close collaboration with the federal
government are actively planning for the
recovery of legal
and clearing the Baidoa mogadishu main
supply routes while operational details
are completed challenges remains in term
of fourth-generation equipment for SNA
and integration of the regional forces
excellencies allow me to to further
remind this forum that in December 2017
it was also agreed that the two other
priorities for immediate action where
the implementation of the national
security architecture and the continued
international support to building the
capacity of Somali security forces and
institutions emerging from progress on
the development of the transitional plan
and the implementation of national
security architecture in echoing the
peace and security council I wish to
call for accelerated efforts by the UN
the larger international community and
the TT CPCC's to urgently support the
federal government in building the
capacity for its security forces and
institutions at the African Union we
have called for an expanded training and
mentoring role for Amazon military and
police component this will rapidly
generate the required security forces to
implement the transition plan in order
to achieve this training the
implementation of national security
architecture requires the immediate
priorities including implementing
implementation of the aura
recommendation and strengthening of the
federal security model B federal
government and federal Member States
implementation of the integration of
regional forces into SNA and SPF C
development of SNA that it's capable of
implementing the transitional plan
through retraining existing SNA troops
to undertake joint operation with Amazon
the sustainability for integrated forces
through regular payment of salaries and
provision of barracks a federal
government to provide funding to
operationalize the regional security
council and security offices the African
roommates encouraged by the federal
government's leadership plan to retire
the
sna troops that have reached retirement
age regarding the funding of Amazon the
Africa Union notes that Amazon's
continued presence and its role within
the transition will necessitate the
securing of predictable and sustainable
funding both for Amazon and the Somali
security institutions consequently the
African looks forward to the outcome of
the next step following the UN Security
Council consideration of invoice report
on Amazon financing as noted by the
invoice in the reports and highlighted
again in recent joint review Amazon must
undergo transformation Amazon's
transformation will compel it to
reorganizing and reconfiguring itself to
meet the demands of the ongoing
transition however taking into
consideration the challenges faced by
the Somali security forces AMISOM is
likely to encounter difficulties with
the further drop down resulting in a
potential reversal of gains in this
regard the African peace and security
council has welcomed the recommendation
of joint review to delay the 1,000 troop
reduction due in October to February 20
1910 during an assessment of Amazon
capabilities this assessment is also
expected to demonstrate the urgent need
to reconfigure Amazon civil component to
both meet the new demands of Amazon
uniformed personnel and the transition
already Amazon is in the final planning
phase of deploying its advanced team of
civilians comprising stabilization and
political officers to federal Member
States to begin substantive work in
conclusion the Africa Union wishes to
underline its full commitment to
strengthen its partnership with the
federal government through the existing
Somalia Africa Union joint task force
with the aim of supporting Somalia in
its pursuit of peace and stability we
want also to thank Europe Union and all
partners in this common endeavor I want
to thank you for your kind attention
thank you and let me now turn the floor
to Rosemary DiCarlo un
under-secretary-general for political
affairs Thank You High Representative
mr. president excellencies ladies and
gentlemen it's my great pleasure to be
with you today we meet as Somalia opens
a new chapter in its history one that
has the potential to fundamentally
transform the country the transition
plan we have been discussing represents
significant progress in affirming Somali
ownership of security we commend the
federal government of Somalia and
federal Member States for the strong
political will they have demonstrated
the priorities they have set must now
guide our activities and be the anchor
of our common engagement in the country
mutual accountability should drive the
implementation of the transition plan
but implementation will not be possible
without adequate resources and
commiserate political will many partners
have made significant contributions to
the stabilization process it is critical
that we now align our existing and
future support to the priorities
outlined in the plan and channel
required funding through Somalia's
national systems the United Nations is
fully committed to Somalia's future and
will support implementation of the plan
through its UN missions in Somalia and
relevant UN agencies excellencies let me
pay tribute to the ultimate sacrifice
that Amazon has made its presence
remains critical while Somalia bills
it's security capacity we look to the
African Union and Amazon troop
contributing countries to begin the
reconfiguration called for in the plan
and we look to the European Union to
maintain its investment in Amazon the
United Nations ready to work with the
African Union and other partners to
broaden the base of financial
contributions to the force excellencies
progress in Somalia will only be
sustained
by political agreement that forms the
basis of the federal state we commend
the leaders of both the federal
government and federal member states for
recent agreements that chart a path to
universal suffrage elections over the
next six months there will be a need to
advance the constitutional review in
particular agreement on the allocation
of power and resource sharing is
necessary genuine inclusivity of federal
Member States parliamentarians clan
power brokers the private sector and
civil society is essential as is the
meaningful participation of women the
United Nations is ready to step up it's
good offices advice and assistance in
support of this political roadmap
political progress will also be the
basis for further economic reforms we
commend the federal government for its
significant efforts to put the country
on a sounder economic and financial
footing these reforms will promote
economic development and reduce
Somalia's reliance on external aid we
also welcome the government's approach
to tackling these resilience and
recovery and we call on all partners to
engage with the resilience and recovery
framework and support investments that
link humanitarian and development work
and promote long-term growth these
reforms will ultimately strengthen
Somalia's resistance against internal
and external pressures we encourage all
to work in a constructive spirit to
support the federal system and respect
Somalia's unity we should prevent
internal and external conflicts from
undermining progress in Somalia
excellencies we have been working to
provide a future of peace and prosperity
and a sovereign Somalia it is time to
invest in progress to make it
irreversible in order to achieve our
common goal of a lasting peace in that
country thank you
thank you let me really warmly welcome
and thank first of all the President of
the Federal Republic of Somalia the
African Union Commission the United
Nations my partner in co-hosting and Co
chairing this forum Sweden for this
opening session of our partnership forum
I would like now to invite before we
proceed with the first session of our
works the heads of delegation to follow
us for a family photo and then we'll
immediately come back to this room to
proceed with the summary on the outcomes
of the priorities by the Deputy Prime
Minister and then with the interventions
from the different delegations thank you
you're just gonna want this back
I just messed this yeah sorry